[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire au programme aujourd'hui
deux figures du scandale
l'écrivain gustave flaubert et
l'humoriste louis siquet je reçois en
effet régis jauffret qui à l'occasion du
200e anniversaire de la naissance de
l'auteur de madame bovary publie le
dernier bain de gustave flaubert et
guillaume aurignac l'auteur de rire
autant de la honte une histoire de louis
siquet et dont on commence tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de 21ème siècle
alors voici leurs réponses en images
on commence par la vôtre guillaume
aurignac qu'est ce qu'elle représente
alors là ce qu'on voit donc en fait
c'est une photo qui date de janvier
dernier en fait et qui au musée grévin
ou en fait ils prennent la
représentation donald trump et vont le
mettre dans les caves du musée et ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette photo c'est que
il ya littéralement une décapitation du
presse de l'ex président américain et
aussi le fait que les deux personnes qui
s'en occupent et portent des masques
et c'est comme si symboliquement il y
avait l'idée que le temps des bouffons
en politique était peut-être terminée
parce que on était revenu à la gravité
au sérieux liés à cette épidémie qu'on
connaît depuis un an maintenant
donc c'est la question je me suis posé
ce que le temps des bouffons est
vraiment terminée d'autant plus que
trump ces derniers jours est revenu
ce faire des interviews notamment à
foxnews pour dire qu'il allait revenir à
la maison blanche ce qui va amuser dans
le portrait que trump qui était au musée
grévin c'est que je m'explique comment
peut-on raté à ce point sa coiffure elle
est quand même très caractéristiques et
sa statue au musée grévin n'était
absolument pas coiffée comme le
président des états unis
alors c'est à dire qu'il est même
presque mieux coiffée que que dans la
réalité en fait aimer ce qui est amusant
c'est que et c'est qu'il est le vrai
président train pleuvrait donald trump
fait beaucoup plus
pantin figure de cire que le que sa
représentation au musée grévin
alors voici maintenant l'image choisie
par régis jauffret celle ci je vois bien
ou ce qu'elle représente mais pourquoi
c'est le site
bah écoutez moi j'ai une photo d'hôpital
on me présente cet hôpital qui convient
tout à fait alors bon aujourd'hui on
sait très bien pourquoi on peut choisir
cette image mais je crois que je
l'aurais choisi avant la pandémie parce
que on est une époque qui est dans un
idéal de longévité
c'est là que c'est très frappant de voir
que les les directeurs les patrons des
gaffes à mes créateurs dégâts femmes
leur rêve suprême c'est la longévité
c'est l'éternité
c'est la première fois que une espèce
animale si j'ose dire
son idéal c'est le longévité c'est la
première fois qu'on imagine allonger la
durée de vie d'une espèce de mammifère
parce que par exemple vous avez les
éléphants qui vivent peut vivre jusqu'à
100 ans mais c'est le cas depuis
l'origine des éléphants tandis que nous
notre rêve c'est un rêve de longévité
c'est à dire on a le rêve de durée voilà
et avant on avait ce rêve de durée et de
perdurer à travers sa ligne et sa
descendance
les rois qui crée une créer un royaume
les empereur napoléon voulais durer mes
parents vivent éternellement il voulait
que son fils lui succède et de fils de
son fils et c'est nous c'est nous mêmes
qui vont nous succéder à nous-mêmes
éternellement et je pense que l'hôpital
symbolise
quand même réfléchir au frais avant on
rêvait de l'éternité mais dans le de la
laquette d'immortels voilà un au fond
est aussi ancienne on pourrait dire que
que l'humanité oui mais pas
l'immortalité ici bas si je veux dire je
pense que c'est la première fois on a
essayé toujours de guérir des maladies
mais maintenant on en est à vouloir
changer le programme même de l'humain
c'est à dire qui est programmé soit
disant pour vivre 120 ans mais par
exemple des gens les gens dégâts femmes
ne sont pas satisfaits parce que en
réalité je pense aussi quand on est
extrêmement riche
on ne comprend pas pourquoi on va mourir
pour ça qu'il ya des gens riches qui
vont faire congeler leurs leur corps
parce que comme ils peuvent tout acheter
ils comprennent pas que ça il peut ils
sont même rang que l'ouvrier du coin ou
que le cadre du coin ou que leurs
employés et je pense que c'est très
s'est réduit à ça et en même temps on
arrive à ajouter foi à des imbécilités
sous prétexte que ça va être des gens
qui ont qui sont à la base de 2
google ou de je ne sais quoi c'est à
dire que ce serait n'importe qui qui
raconterait les choses qui raconte-t-on
les enverrait se faire voir mais comme
ils ont réussi dans la vie on les écoute
par exemple j'ai entendu cette
imbécillité de quelqu'un qui travaille
chez google mais un très haut niveau qui
était un des patrons d'ailleurs qui
disait que dans dix ans les gens ne
ferait plus l'amour parce qu'ils
pourraient se connecter sur des machines
qui défraie éprouvé beaucoup plus de
jouissance c'est évidemment complètement
stupide
voilà mais comme c'était quelqu'un issu
des gars femmes eh ben on l'a écouté et
bien commençons
[Musique]
régis jauffret vous êtes l'auteur d'une
trentaine de livres pourquoi est ce que
vous avez eu envie de raconter la vie de
flaubert dans ce roman le dernier bain
gustave flaubert qui vient de paraître
au seuil
c'est quand même pas par opportunisme
parce qu on célèbre cette année le 200e
anniversaire de l'année de sa naissance
et même si c'était le cas vous aviez le
choix je crois qu'on fait également le
150e anniversaire de la naissance de
proust le 130e anniversaire de la mort
d'arthur rimbaud le centenaire de
georges brassens les 30 ans de la mort
de gainsbourg
vous avez préféré flaubert pourquoi en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que moi je
voulais créer un livre sauf lauber parce
que c'était un compagnon d'écriture ce
que je veux dire depuis l'âge de 18 ans
quand j'avais découvert le premier tome
de la pléiade de sa correspondance qui
venait de paraître et donc j'avais
cheminer avec lui parce que c'est un
écrivain qui surtout dans l'est dans le
premier tome d'ailleurs début de sa vie
c'est son parcours d'écrivain il raconte
ses techniques entre guillemets
d'écriture son idéal de
du style et de et de la narration mais
non moi j'avais eu l'idée un peu avant
mais j'étais allé à à rouen donc sur les
traces de flaubert à rouen où il en
reste peu et c'est là où on m'a parlé du
bicentenaire on me dit est ce qu'on
viendrait pour le bicentenaire est
vivement effectivement ça correspond
mais là ce moment là je me suis dit oui
je vais le sortir l'année du
bicentenaire pendant avant et non après
d'ailleurs ça a coïncidé tout à fait
avec le moment que j'ai terminé le livre
alors donc la raison pour laquelle j'ai
voulu écrire deux sur flaubert c'est
celle là
alors après je me suis retrouvé devant
la possibilité d'écrire une biographie
et là j'ai eu un problème c'est à dire
que ça vient un peu de l'école on m'a
toujours dit faut pas copier
donc j'ai un gros problème à copier ce
qu'elle a déjà été écrit encore plus
faire des copier coller est en réalité
les biographies de flaubert y en a un
certain nombre est à peu près tout est
dit quand même donc on est quand même
conduit à répéter ce qui a déjà été dit
ce qui est normal parce que après ce
serait plus flaubert donc bah écoutez
peu à peu je me suis orienté vers un
travail en quelque sorte d'acteur c'est
que je me suis pas pris pour flaubert
parce que je suis quand même pas
complètement imbécile mais j'ai joué le
rôle de flaubert un peu simplement je
parle acteurs sur une scène jeune
écrivain donc je me suis mis dans la
peau entre guillemets de flaubert cent
cinquante ans après sa main voilà et je
me suis mis dans la peau de flaubert qui
revient sur son passé et qui raconte sa
vie je voudrais saluer tout de suite une
originalité à ma connaissance est le
premier à le faire c'est le chutier qui
à la fin du livre un peu kobia dans les
dvd les scènes coupées au montage
là vous avez publié votre chute y est
sûre c'est une très bonne idée mais
c'est toujours un peu risqué 1
on ce diable c'est dommage il aurait dû
le mettre c'était mieux ou pourquoi pas
ce que vous avez fait ce choix là
et est ce que vous êtes le premier
d'ailleurs je sais pas si je suis le
premier mois j'avais je tire le mot
justice qu'à un moment j'ai vraiment
fait du montage vidéo il y avait dans
l'est dans les logiciels et le chutier
c'est là où vous mettez les scènes et en
effet ou dont vous vous servez pas non
là le luthier c'est une partie très
importante pour moi mais j'ai voulu que
ce soit un peu comme une crypte c'est à
dire que c'est écrit extrêmement petit
ce qui met beaucoup reproché mais ses
paroles prochains mois c'est reprocher
l'éditeur opposent çà ladrerie de pas
vouloir avoir ajouté des pages qui
n'était pas du tout le cas d angers
s'est moqué lutter avec l'éditeur
bouquet ce côté crypte via les passages
extrêmement important pour moi je crois
que les deux pins les paraphes les plus
importants pour moi dans ce livre sont à
la fin du futile justement sont les
parce que j'ai voulu
j'ai voulu un peu c'est un peu de
totalité c'est à dire que j'ai vu que le
livre soit fusée un peu comme
comme un roman de flaubert finalement
que ce soit qui est une construction
rigoureuse que qui est le moins possible
j'ai voulu m'attarder le moins possible
sur les sur les sujets et donc par
exemple toute l'histoire sur le procès
de flaubert qui me conduit à parler de
la de la façon la littérature peut être
traitée dans les tribunaux que j'excuse
dans le roman et que je développe dans
le jus thiais et si vous voulez je me
sens plus à l'aise pour développer mais
ça n'a en aucun cas des brouillons c'est
à dire que c'est des logis tiges les
revues aussi longtemps et jusqu'au
dernier moment comme j'ai pu revoir le
roman alors on s'est beaucoup de choses
sur la vie de robert vous avez vous
l'avais dit il ya beaucoup de
biographies il ya sa correspondance qui
est très importante qui nous permette
dater précisément et dans laquelle il
s'est beaucoup livré il ya des romans de
jeunesse autobiographique comme mémoires
d'un fou évidemment le cas comment vous
vous êtes situez vous parce que vous
vous êtes dit c'est une biographie une
autobiographie romanesque puisque vous
mettez dans la peau de flaubert il ya
tout ce que l'on sait et puis est-ce que
vous allez inventer créer imaginer le
réalité je me suis tenu d
un principe peut tout à fait flaubertien
enfin en fait parce que quand il a écrit
sale un mot il est allé sur les traces
de carthage et s'est aperçu qu'il
restait presque rien donc il écrit
hassan ben je crois il lui dis je ce que
je veux c'est que ce que j'écris ne
puisse pas être contredit par ce qui
reste en fait
et moi j'ai voulu ce que j'ai écrit
d'imaginaire c'est pour essayer d'aller
dans certaines directions et ne pas en
même temps être construit contredit par
ce qu'on sait de la vie ou de ce qu'a pu
dire flaubert voilà ça a été le cadre
c'est à dire c'est pas du tout moi ce
qui m'ont été le plus facile c'est de
partir dans l'imaginaire dès le départ
et en fait quand j'écris un sujet quand
j'écris un livre avec un sujet de départ
qui vient du réel
pour moi le réel c'est un c si vous
voulez je m'en sers comme garde-fou mais
je m'en sers celle d'un point à 16 pour
moi de ne servir de la réalité parce que
j'ai toujours tendance à mon échappée et
donc voilà sur flaubert j'ai je m'en
suis tenu à cette méthode
alors c'est écrit à la première personne
c'est donc flaubert qui écrit en tout
cas toute la première partie dure du
roman alors on le sait c'est assez à la
mode dans la littérature française de
décrire d autobiographie romancée de de
gens célèbres mais là c'est carrément
l'un des plus grands prosateurs de la
langue française donc c'est assez
culotté quand vous faites parler donc
vous fait écrire flaubert évidemment et
ben là c'est au delà de jouer à flaubert
c'est écrire comme flaubert
oui j'ai même pensé que ça pouvait être
une autre j'ai même pas pensé à ça oui
oui c'est une c'est une audace mais
comme il n'y avait pas d'ambiguïté de ma
part de me prendre pour lui ou d'avoir
la prétention pas la prétention parce
que je veux dire ça ce serait même une
forme d'humilité alors là je n'ai pas
parce que finalement moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est d'être moi au sens ce
qui m'intéresse c'est d'écrire un livre
à moi donc il n'y a pas du tout de n'y
avait pas du tout ce complexe là parce
que j'avais pas du tout l'ambiguïté me
dire je vais me mesurer à flaubert ce
qu'ils ont été vains est complètement
absurde et même stupide donc j'ai pas vu
ce problème à ce que je n'ai pas pensé
les dix ans que le fait il pas pensé du
toit assez d'être sorti ça comme vous
avez dû penser en revanche c'est là
aussi moi j'y vois une audace c'est de
raconter une vie qui a priori et sans
intérêt ce que la vie de flaubert et
sans intérêt c'est à dire que il qu il
grandit dans la bourgeoisie normande
il a des crises d'épilepsie il va
hériter assez tôt de son père dont il va
devenir un petit rentiers modeste il va
vivre dans un hameau crois c'est au bord
de la seine écrire écrire ses romans il
en n'a pas publié tellement il a
quasiment aucune histoire d'amour
intéressante
et s'il n'y avait pas eu le procès qu'on
va lui faire pour madame bovary et son
voyage en orient dont on va reparler là
et l'autre qui pour des raisons
différentes sont des motifs de scandale
il ne lui serait rien arrivé du tout et
c'est ce qui fait peut-être le grand
romancier qui l'a été d'ailleurs
oui il n'y a pas eu glissez pas il n'a
pas une vie extraordinairement
mouvementée il a une vie plus
mouvementée que marcel proust par
exemple marcel proust à une vie encore
moins il a encore moins de choses oui
mais il a rencontré plus de gens proust
ou et balzac il a eu un voyage en russie
mais savoir madame ans ko mais vous ne
l'a pas fait grand chose en plus oui
c'est une vie d'écrivain journée tout à
fait d'accord maintenant il est quand
même arrivé des événements sur un plan
privé c'est à dire que si vous voulez
n'importe quelle vie n'importe quelle
vie quand vous pencher sur une vie s'est
toujours passé des myriades de choses
mais ce sont des événements privés qui
de loin n'ont pas d'intérêt mais qui dès
qu'on s'en rapproche peuvent sont toute
une histoire
nous somme toute une histoire pour nous
mêmes et même pour des gens qui se
pencherait sur notre sur notre vie
26 s'est pas passé grand chose alors il
se trouve qu'il a eu un amour platonique
très important flaubert c'est avec élise
à jeter singer qui va lui aspirer
énormément de choses dans ses romans
elle avait dix ans de plus que lui elle
était mariée et alors là vous le vous le
faites coucher avec elle c'est possible
après tout rien ne peut le contredire
alors qu'a priori on pense qu'il ne
s'est rien passé et et puis vous vous
raconter qu'elle avait été violé en
réunion le jour de ses noces
je suis peut-être que vous avez des
informations que je ne connaissais pas
mais voilà d'où ça sort ça vous
attendant c'est tout à fait exact
laquelle je me serais pas permis les le
viol en réunion dont vous parlez le jour
de ses noces est tout à fait exact
le fait qu'elle ait été acheté en
quelque sorte à maurice t 5 g tous les
chemins guerre j'ai des problèmes avec
les prononciations
à son mari qui avait été bon exilé en
algérie pour faire la guerre et c'est
tout à fait exact
c'est une fable qui était complètement
martyrs dès le départ c'est tout à fait
vrai son mari l'a enfin chez singer l'a
épousée alors qu'elle était toujours
marié donc il pouvait pas l'épouser et
il a même reconnu un enfant alors qu'il
n'était pas du mari mais qui étaient
d'un comte allemand
je cite le nom et c'est très étrange
parce que pour que cet enfant ne soit
pas bâtard étant donné qu'elle était
mariée
il l'a reconnu cet enfant et il a été
inscrit sur l'état physique civile de
mère inconnue de mer c'est tout à fait
exact
quand on fait que flaubert et pu avoir
une relation sexuelle avec avec elle
franchement c'est une possibilité
c'est à dire qu'on a une histoire
sordide racontée par les frères goncourt
qui les aime beaucoup et que je n'ai pas
envie de raconter là et qui ferait qu'au
dernier moment il n'a pas pu s'exécuter
on va dire ça comme ça mais le fait
qu'il ait pu avoir une relation sexuelle
à un certain moment entre est très
possible parce que flaubert mais à part
ça était très sentimental c'est
quelqu'un qui l'a vu jusqu'à la fin de
ses jours
même de façon sporadique c'est tout à
fait
c'est tout à fait possible et alors il
ya il ya une grande amitié dans la vie
de flaubert c'est avec alfred le
poitevin qui était le fils de du parrain
de gustave flaubert
c'était donc deux familles qui étaient
très proches et vous en faites un couple
quasiment homosexuels là aussi il ya
qu'est ce qui vous permet de le penser
non j'en fais pas un couple jeudi qu'ils
ont une relation non pas d'amitié
soyons clairs a pas une relation
d'amitié avec un frêne le pot-de-vin
il ya une passion amoureuse entre
l'huile fred le poitevin et tout laisse
à penser dans les brumes qui peut rester
que c'est une nation qui était sexuelle
également et vous que et en plus
d'autant plus scandaleuse je n'en parle
pas dans le livre parce qu'il trouve pas
ça passionnant mais d'autant plus
scandaleux ce qu'ils avaient cinq ans
d'écart donc qui ont flambé avec 14 ans
il en avait 19 et donc il a cette
passion a commencé très tôt donc oui une
passion mais une passion mais c'est la
passion de sa vie
c'est l'homme de sa vie il en a été
veuve quentin frais de poids de 20 est
mort compte donc il avait trente deux
ans nous que flaubert à 27
c'est un c'est un vin flaubert il a été
veuve deux fois il a été vain la
première fois quand alfred le poitevin
s'est marié
ça a été une catastrophe pour lui ça a
été une trahison il a vécu ça comme une
trahison épouvantable parce qu'ils
avaient fait le voeu de ne jamais se
marier de rester des hommes de l'art des
célibataires par des animateurs de l'art
justement comment on parle d'une pause
mais des célibataires pour l'art et donc
ça a été une catastrophe pour lui son
mariage et la mort 2
oui la mort d'alfred le poitevin et de
sa soeur caroline ça a sonné pour lui
vraiment le glas du bonheur il a pu
vraiment être heureux
après ces deux événements vous l'avez
dit il avait 14 ans alfred le poids
devant en avait 19
aujourd'hui ça tomberait sous le coup de
la loi les deux scandales
dont je parlais tout à l'heure c'est
évidemment celui de madame bovary
on va pas revenir dessus est très connue
faut savoir qu'à l'époque le divorce
n'existait pas donc ce qui fait scandale
à l'époque de la parution de madame
bovary évidemment ne fait plus scandale
aujourd'hui celle inverse en revanche
pour le voyage en orient et d'ailleurs
vous fait dire à à gustave flaubert dans
le roman que c'est un foutu voyage qui à
vos yeux de contemporains là il parle de
nous fait de moi un
1 une ordure une ordure et pour cause
puisque on pensait d'ailleurs il ne s'en
est pas caché non seulement il a
fréquenté les bordels pendant ce voyage
en orient qui l'emmène en egypte
jérusalem à constantinople mais en plus
il aurait eu des relations avec des
enfants
et de même pour maxime du camp non je
n'avais pas jusque là je peux revenir en
détail mais non en orient c'est qu'il a
eu des relations des passants avec des
mineurs parce que ça se passait avec des
ctd des jeunes des éphèbes ce qu'il
appelait l'oeuvre des bains c'est à dire
c'était là la sodomie
c'était la grande question c'est est
découvrir la sodomie qui a priori c'est
très curieux qui la découvre en orient
parce que bon on peut imaginer qu'en
france elle existait aussi mais non les
histoires d'enfants c'est plutôt du côté
de caen de maxime du camp qui d'alors
c'est dans ce qui nous reste mes skis et
ski est là où je fais un amalgame si
vous voulez c'est que ce sont dans des
lettres qui nous restent à flaubert mais
qui a aucune critique là dessus de la
part de flaubert parce qu'il revient là
dessus sur ce genre de chose en parlant
à d'autres amis sur un plan ironique etc
mais je veux dire c'est est
culturellement normalement ça ne leur
posait aucun problème c'est dans la
morale de l'époque qui existaient qui
était corsetée ce genre de choses
n'existe pas c'est à dire que une
prostituée qui était puisqu'on a un
récit pouvant table de maxime du camp
mais là qui se passe en france avec une
prostituée qui a une douzaine d'années
ça n'était pas plus blâmable que si elle
avait eu 25 ans voilà c'est ça c'est
cette morale de l'époque j'ai voulu
souligner c'est une question qu'on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas donner son
opinion personnelle c'est très curieux
dire qu'on peut donner une idée comme un
objet qui se serait détaché la réalité
c'est que c'était des gens qui
respectent elle l'a plus ou moins comme
nous plus ou moins la morale de leur
temps et là on est en l1 acronis mais
pas seulement sur eux on sera en
accro'nat un anachronisme sur énormément
de sujets et
ils sont criminels mais à l'époque ce
n'était pas un crime et s'était même pas
une faute
en plus il ya le fait et ça c'est
historique ou s'ils m'ont considéré et
ses dents c'est toute l'histoire du
colonialisme aussi que c'était des races
inférieures donc qui pouvait se passer
en orient finalement ça n'était pas avec
une humanité qui avait la valeur de
l'humanité qui pouvait être en france
tout ce qui fait qu'on est dans un
imbroglio complet et que c'est
extrêmement difficile même de l'évoquer
pour ça qu'il ya une différence demeure
effectivement projeté sur lorient
d'autres moeurs que les nôtres un
dernier point sur sur flaubert une
croissance scandale c'est quand même que
son génie à l'époque n'est reconnu que
par les génies au fond il se présentera
pas la clim française vous l'aï dit
parce qu'il fallait y penser qu'il avait
aucune chance pas plus que zola ou
baudelaire en fait à l'époque on prête
du génie au nul et pas au génie là aussi
il ya un anachronisme
comme vous y allez non on peut dire
quand même qu'on lui a prêtées du génie
et que même on lui a prêté du génie et
même avant d'avoir publié ses amis
savaient déjà que c'est un génie après
ce titre c'est le marais pas le public
est pas la critique mais c'est mal
milieu la critique oui mais c'était
c'est plutôt le commerce qui suivaient
pas le problème de flaubert c'est qu'à
la fin de sa vie il a été ruiné par son
vin et que le commerce ne suivait pas
ses axes étaient pas aulas et c'était
pas alexandre dumas père que ses ventes
étaient très réduites
donc quand ils demandaient de l'argent
aux éditeurs parce qu il n avait un
pressant besoin on lui donnait pas parce
que ses ventes étaient lamentables et ce
qui est vrai et là je me suis tout à
fait c'est que après sa mort tout de
suite après sa mort les choses ont
explosé le marché du livre de flaubert a
explosé mais en effet c'était
il avait autour de lui un milieu assez
assez cultivé comme comme gauthier une
époque comme les frères goncourt quand
il était vivant tous les deux comme
comme zola comme tourguéniev d'ailleurs
tourguéniev qui était un grand alter ego
de de flaubert et ça a été quand vous
lisez la correspondance c'est très
étrange et assez pathétique parce que
c'est le dernier vivant
en gros c'est le dernier correspondant
vivant il y avait encore edmond de
goncourt mais des témoins proche
d'edmond de goncourt et la symbiose la
dernière symbio c'est avec tourguéniev
le dernier bain de gustave flaubert
c'est le nouveau roman de régis jauffret
qui vient de paraître au seuil
[Musique]
guillaume gnac vous vous êtes
réalisateur de courts-métrages critique
de cinéma et vous sortez aux éditions
façonnage rire autant de la honte c'est
une histoire de louis siquet qui était
devenu le roi du stand up aux etats-unis
également très admirée en france
notamment par les humoristes et qui
s'est retrouvé balayé en quelques jours
par la vague bits ou lorsqu'il a été
accusé par cinq femmes de s'être
masturbé en leur présence sans leur
consentement
ce qui l'a reconnu il a dit qu'il avait
je le cite abusé de l'admiration qu'elle
lui portait la sanction ne s'est pas
fait attendre louis siquet a disparu
littéralement sans autre forme de procès
victime de la cancel culture qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie d'écrire sur
louis siquet et ben ça a été d'abord la
réaction aux révélations donc c'était
dans le new york times sur son
comportement de la part de gens qui
aimaient qui était admirateur de louis
siquet et qui ont dit qu'ils étaient
très déçu par son comportement alors
qu'il me semblait mois que tout ce qu'il
y avait dans son oeuvre s'il vient de
stand-up de fiction puisque c'est aussi
un réalisateur de séries et de films de
films montrés que déjà il y avait d une
forme d'ambiguïté que et qu'en fait ce
qu'on apprenait de son comportement dans
new york times n'était pas si surprenant
que ça finalement
voilà ça c'était la première réaction
qui m'a interpellé la deuxième c'était
mais ça n'a pas grand chose à voir a
priori avec lucic et pc dans le même
mouvement
ces deux mois après il ya une une
une tribune dans libération de leurs
murat et qui c'est qui parlait de blow
up d'antonioni le film d'antonioni et
qui disait notamment dans une scène qui
était une scène de joutes érotique et
qui dit en fait cette scène est une
scène de viol et je n'avais jamais vu
jusqu'à présent
je l'avais pas vu comme une scène de
viol parce qu'en fait expliquait-elle
l'esthétique d'antonioni caché que
c'était une scène de viol et j'ai relié
un peu ces deux réactions et je me suis
dit en fait à chaque fois il ya un
problème de on ne voit pas ce qu'on
devrait voir en fait à chaque fois c'est
certaines réactions la con qui est qui
qui vient et il m'a semblé que justement
ce qui était intéressant le classique et
c'est que tout était là dans son oeuvre
et qu'on avait voulu paradoxalement
effacé l'oeuvre alors que l'oeuvre avait
des choses à nous apprendre sur lui et
sur notre rapport avec lui au même temps
que disparaît ou ici qu'est disparaît
également kevin ce pays si pour d'autres
raisons mais mais mais quand même assez
similaire la différence c'est que louis
siquet comme vous le racontez est
parvenu à revenir pas kevin ce pays si
oui ce ticket et a refait un spectacle
dans une petite salle cours au départ et
puis les revenus et puis les revenus et
y est sa carrière à recommencer même si
le film qu'il avait réalisé et
interprété produit n'est jamais sorti et
que la plupart de ces séries ont disparu
des plateformes qui les hébergeait il a
recommencé sa carrière de comédien il a
recommencé pour une simple et bonne
raison c'est que c'est sa discipline
c'est le stand-up et le stand up c'est
un micro une salle et il faut que le
public vienne est en fait tant qu'il a
un public il a ce rapport direct avec le
public
eh ben c'est pas très compliqué pour lui
de revenir parce que ça ne lui coûte pas
grand chose en fait
kevin ce pc c'est un acteur et idées
temps du regard de l'industrie sur lui
si l'industrie de ne plus lui il
disparaît et en fait il a disparu
louis sic et ne dépend pas du regard de
l'industrie sur lui dépend du regard du
public sur lui et l'a construit
toutes ces années avant d'être avant ces
révélations dans la presse une relation
directe avec le public direct au point
où même en dehors du stand-up même sur
ces séries sa dernière série qui
s'appelait horasan pitt une série de 10
épisodes il là il a autoproduite payer
lui-même avec sa province au propre
argent est il à donner sur les réseaux à
partir de son site internet
donc il y avait aucune médiation il
avait un rapport direct avec le public
et c'est ce qui lui a permis de revenir
sans que ce soit comment dire un peu
surface or ce soit ça a été contestée
mais ça n'a pas été rendue impossible
les tue pas tout à fait d'accord avec
vous il y est mort il n'ya que c'est que
on a eu le cas en france avec bertrand
cantat qui une fois avoir purgé sa peine
de prison a pensé qu'ils pouvaient
revenir chanter de nouveau et on a bien
vu que quand tu as été assez indépendant
aussi noir désir avait bâti une carrière
indépendamment on peut le dire de
l'industrie et des médias
néanmoins quand il est remonté sur scène
ça a choqué tellement de monde que ça
l'a quasiment empêché de continuer ça
aurait pu être la même chose aux états
unis avec louis siquet est-ce que ça a
choqué son retour sur scène il y en a
qui l'ont mal pris
alors ça a choqué une partie il faut
savoir que quand il est revenu il est
revenu à l'été fin août 2010 8 je crois
donc plus d'un an après les révélations
et dans une petite salle comme font les
gens de stand-up c'est à dire qu'ils
vont se retrouver parfois dans des
petites salles des gens pas la première
fois mais la deuxième fois de la reprise
et la deuxième représentation des gens
se sont levés dans la salle sont partis
ou ont sifflé voilà donc il ya eu des
remous et dans la presse on a dit non il
ne présente aucune excuse donc on ne
veut pas le revoir
voilà la différence n'est pas une
différence il ya je verrai deux points
différents entre bertrand cantat et
louis siquet la première c'est que ce
café bertrand cantat sur le plan
métaphysique sa emporte tout le
personnage un moment un crime un
assassinat
sas a remporté tout la vie d'une
personne voilà lui sic et ce n'est pas
exactement ça donc en fait on peut
encore le voir à mon avis sur sept c'est
encore admissible est le deuxième point
qui est différent c'est que bertrand
cantat est revenu avec des chansons
encore un peu militante un peu voilà
comment comment utiliser avec noir désir
et qui était en porte à faux totale avec
ce qu'on connaît de lui
finalement de son comportement voilà
alors que louis siquet quand il revient
il revient avec sa comédie qu'est une
comédie d'auto une obligation de lui
même et en fait c'est cohérent
en fait avec ce qu'il a ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a fait vous dites d'ailleurs qu'il
ya il a pas il est pas il est pas tombé
dans la contrition 1
or c'est souvent ce qu'on attend des
gens qui ont fauté et notamment dans la
grande salle culture on voudrait qu'ils
passent leur vie ensuite à a demandé
pardon
et ça n'est pas son cas et c'est
d'autant plus facile dites-vous que il a
toujours donné le spectacle de ses
obsessions sexuelles et
et et tout le monde trouvait ça drôle
jusqu'à présent et ça d'ailleurs vous
vous interrogez ce ce paradoxe c'est que
tout ce qu'ils trouvaient ça drôle quand
il se décrivait lui même en train de se
masturber devant des devant une telle ou
unetelle ne font plus trouvé ça drôle
quand à partir du moment où ils
l'avaient fait vraiment enfin on peut
comprendre que c'est pas la même chose
de le dire et d'en rire que de le faire
non c'est clairement pas la même chose
après ce mois je trouve que ce qu'il ya
de de paradoxal là dedans dans ses
réactions ses de revisiter tout ça toute
son oeuvre sa comédie en dix ans
finalement c'est dégoûtant
alors qu'en fait il trouvait ça très
drôle voilà et et il a toujours joué là
dessus sur cette idée qu'en fait quand
on va au fond du dégoût il ya aussi
l'humour ça continue à être drôle
voilà et et je crois que c'était assez
salutaire
et ça continue de l'être et c'était je
trouve que j'ai toujours j'ai trouvé ça
dommage que d'un seul coup on le lui
reproche
pour des parce que les faits étant et
pour constater puisque le mien me lisa
et les amis ça ne remet pas en cause le
l'idée que sa comédie était avait
produisez quelque chose d'intéressant
sur notre rapport au monde et n'aura pas
en pull sion à tout ce qui est a priori
tout ce qu'on cache tout ce que nos
civilité veut le veut mettre sous le
tapis
et en plus il est il est véritablement
louis siquet danse danses et sketches
il joue avec l'obscénité c'est très
important l'obscénité dans son travail
et vous dit d'ailleurs qu'il est bébé
n'est pas le premier le premier c'était
sans doute lady bonus qui lui a payé le
prix fort on va le voir
lenny bruce ici il a été depuis
interprété par dustin hoffman au cinéma
mais voilà quelqu'un qui a vraiment
extrêmement souffert la police débarquer
interrompait son spectacle s'est drogué
il a été emporté par les procès qu'on
lui fait
il ya urgence car l'hymne aussi richard
pryor
voilà un e3 on pourrait dire qu'ils ont
ouvert la voie à louis siquet co
complètement en fait ce sont les lenny
bruce et le grand modernisateur du
stand-up qui a qui a travaillé pour que
ça ne devienne une sorte de conversation
brillante et humoristique sur toutes
sortes de sujets et surtout et et après
où il a travaillé au moment des années
50 et au début des années 60 et il a
essayé de ramener tous les sujets qu'on
cache est en fait dans cette amérique un
peu de classe moyenne très conventionnel
qu'on voulait pas mettre sur scène en
fait hélas voulurent donc ramené et
notamment beaucoup de la sexualité en
fait voilà tout et reprend sa tension
sexuelle au moment où on fait la loi
considéré que c'était obscènes et que ça
n'était c'était interdit en fait ce
n'était pas protégée par le premier
amendement sur la liberté d'expression
et et le tout travail de lenny bruce a
été de lutter contre ça et de dire j'ai
le droit de parler de questions
sexuelles sur scène parce que je suis un
satiriste je ne suis pas un pornographe
est en fait il a échoué voilà il a perdu
son dernier procès en 1964 il a échoué
il est mort deux ans après d'une
overdose à moitié un suicide à moitié
d'ouverts doses parce qu'en fait voilà
il ne pouvait plus travailler mais en
fait il a ouvert la voie parce qu à sa
suite les comédiens sont montés sur
scène on continue à travailler dans ce
registre là ils ont fini non ils ont
fini par gagner
finalement parce que la représentation
auxerre des choses obscène a été
considérée comme finalement et en
faisant partie de la liberté
d'expression dans les années 70 voilà il
ya eu un procès notamment sur george
catlin qui est un continuateur de lenny
bruce et qu'un comédien très célèbre
donc des années 70 donc du stand up
américain et qui lui a gagné son procès
sur le droit d'employer des mots des
mots crus des mots obscènes sur scène
alors personne ne discute aujourd'hui le
le droit d'employer des mots crus des
mets en revanche se pose le problème
aujourd'hui 2 qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
sa vie au fond et est ce que l'on fait
dans sa vie peut frapper d'indignité
tout votre oeuvre au fond d'où le titre
de votre livre rire autant de la honte
la honte c'est le mot qu'emploie vous le
rappeler adèle haenel quand elle se lève
de la cérémonie des césar et qu'elle
sort parce qu'on vient de désigner
romane polanski pour le césar de la mise
en scène et est au fond la question
qu'on peut se poser c'est qu'est ce
qu'on peut et est ce qu'il faut de le
choisir entre adèle haenel et louis
siquet est-ce qu'on peut les apprécier
tous les deux trouvé qu'ils sont tous
les deux dans leur droit au fond où est
ce qu'ils sont devenus incompatibles
cc c'est vrai effectivement les grandes
questions parce que moi je crois que
quand la belle anne elle intervient aux
césars et fait vaciller toute la
cérémonie avec ce mot la honte et ce
geste je crois qu'elle a raison elle a
raison je comprends son attitude et et
c'est un retournement
de la honte contre les puissants contre
les contrôles et suborneur parler
suborner en fait voilà en disant c'est à
vous d'avoir honte c'est pas à nous
d'avoir on s'est servi
elle a raison de le faire le problème
avec lui sic et c'est que il est emporté
par cette vague là aussi lui comme
suborneur alors que tout son travail et
non moins c'est ça c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
toute son oeuvre parle justement du
sentiment de honte qu'on peut avoir dans
l'existence est un sentiment qui pour
lui est un sentiment universel quelques
sentiments fondateur est essentiel dans
l'humanité et je trouve que ce soit moi
je trouve dommage c'est que on évacue
toute l'oeuvre à ce moment là qu'on ait
un rapport avec l'outil qu'est en disant
je ne veux pas le voir très bien tout à
fait normal voilà mais après qu'on
veulent qu'on demande à ce que l'oeuvre
disparaissent c'est là où je ne suis pas
d'accord en fait parce que je pense que
l'oeuvre justement pouvez nous aider à
comprendre tout ça est donc un moment il
faut être attentif à ça il faut pas tout
faire disparaître voilà mais louis
siquet encore une fois c'est c'est cia
les paroles et il ya les actes il ya le
dire et il ya l'accomplir et et tout son
éloge permanent de la masturbation
quel que soit et l'obscénité avec
laquelle il peut il pouvait raconter
effectivement qu'il se masturbait ou qui
ne se base sur mes pas d'ailleurs parce
que ça aussi ça peut être très drôle
quand il sait qu'il admirait tellement
scarlett johansson que l sur l île ne se
masturber pas tout ça était très drôle
mais à partir du moment où on estime
qu'il y a eu des victimes
ces cinq femmes qui disent qu'il l'a
fait sans qu'on ne sent qu'on y consent
tout du moins il a essayé de le faire
pour une d'entre elles mais évidemment
ça change totalement
tout ça ne justifie pas qu'on le conte
le quand celle qu'on le fasse
disparaître mais ça pose le problème
autrement
alors on pourrait dire que ça pose
effectivement le problème autrement
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois qu'il va
faire une blague là dessus on va se dire
mais il blague alors qu'il l'a fait
vraiment il a fait réellement et donc
est ce que c'est encore drôle le ce
qu'il ya c'est que cette blague était
toujours accompagné
c'est à dire qu'il vous dit il faisait
l'apologie mais c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça il faisait l'apologie
en même temps il se dénigrer lui-même en
disant je ne suis pas à barack obama par
exemple il se comparait à barack obama
il disait quelle chance il à barack
obama d'être stable il a certainement il
sait que s'il était très conventionnelle
est très tranquille
et du coup c'est un type bien et moi je
suis pas un type bien voilà donc c'est à
la fois drôle
il ya en même temps c'est il ya une
forme de pathétique voilà qu'il
reconnaît qu'il met en scène
voilà alors est-ce qu'on doit lui
interdire du coup ce pathétique parce
que celle c'est vraiment arrivé
et en même temps dans ce qui arrivait
dans l'est les exemples un moment il ya
une une comédienne d'aucuns qui propose
le 2-2 de se masturber devant elle
qu'ils s'appellent rebecca corrie qui
lui dit mais enfin louis tu as une femme
tu as un enfant elle et raconte qui se
met à rougir et qui lit tu as raison
j'ai des problèmes et les reparti voilà
donc un moment la honte le traverse de
part en part quand même et moi voilà
c'est ça on peut pas tout à fait délier
les choses c'est vrai mais en même temps
on ne peut pas oublier l'oeuvre au nom
de ce qui s'est passé parce que ce qui
s'est passé est compliquée et l'oeuvre
est très haut et l'oeuvre parle de cette
compliquer ses complexités là il ya
autre chose dont on ne parle jamais elle
c est ce que c'est grave
loria des victimes donc c'est grave mais
au fond selon la loi française louis
siquet serait coupable de harcèlement
sexuel pas d'agression il n'a pas porté
la main sur sur ses victimes et et
et pas de viol non plus puisqu'il n'y a
pas pénétration donc on attend ce
aujourd'hui à tout mélanger
le harcèlement c'est pas une agression
l'agression c'est pas un viol etc etc et
on a tous et finalement pour des
accusations très différentes
la sanction devient la même c'est à dire
en gros vous disparaissez
vous êtes interdit de travailler plus ou
moins c'est le cas de kevin speccy il
est interdit de travailler aujourd'hui
je crois que c'est bien aussi à un
moment où c'est arrivé c'est à dire que
c'est arrivé dans le sillage de la
sphère weinstein ou là c'était quand
même des allégations enfin des
accusations pour lequel il a été jugé et
condamné qui sont beaucoup beaucoup plus
grave
et du coup je pense que louis siquet a
été emporté par ça aussi c'est à dire
que lui de son point de vue il se rend
des comptes dont il a fait pas un acte
de contrition mais un acte il a expliqué
la situation par dont il a expliqué la
situation
et pourquoi il considérait effectivement
c'était pas bien ce qu'il avait fait
mais ça n'est pas du tout
ça n'est pas du tout le cas faire
weinstein est en fait il a un peu payé
pour ça il a aussi payé pour ça parce
qu'il est il est il arrivé à ce moment
là et donc tout son geste a été pris
dans un effet systémique on va dire de
se dire qu'à partir du moment où
commence à faire ça on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin et se retrouver chez
dans la position david harvey weinstein
est en fait c'est du point de vue des
femmes c'est ça c'est ça qui est
insupportable c'est l'attitude des
hommes qui en fait qui ceux qui se
croient libres de tout faire dans ces
cas là voilà il a été jugé comme ça mais
c'est évidemment beaucoup moins de doute
façon endroit en termes de droits le
droit fait les différences évidemment
donc là-dessus l'a pas été il a eu
aucune conséquence juridique pour lui un
jeu
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'en pense régis
jauffret alors on voit bien que les
problèmes d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas ceux
qui se posaient à l'époque de flaubert
néanmoins comme flaubert comparaît au
tribunal pour madame bovary c'est très
très grave
à l'époque qu'un et c'est aussi grave
que ce qui arrive est louis siquet
aujourd'hui oui ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que il faut on peut regarder les
choses un peu dans le temps parce que
vous avez les déclarations féministes
ont toujours été critiqués qui ont
toujours les familles sont même toujours
été ridiculisé si je me tourne vers
n'ont passé je vois que quand j'étais
jeune il y avait les mains with d'un
côté et les féministes de l'ôter
maoïstes et et était magnifique était
pas du tout critiquer à part pour des
raisons politiques et pas le reste c'est
pour des guerriers et se sait qu'ils
étaient critiquées c'était des
féministes et elle était critiquée même
à la télévision par des gens très très
près comme un possédé c'était une
critique générale et c'est des
féministes qu'on fait avancer les choses
par les maoïstes
voilà oui vous avez raison sur le fait
de
l'histoire de madame bovary mais je vais
prendre un exemple qui met encore plus
personnel le vous savez l'époque avancé
avance très vite mans par exemple ya
quelques années il ya 4 ou 5 ans j'ai
été plus j'ai été condamné pour lui que
j'avais écrit sur dominique strauss kahn
on a dit que j'avais j'ai jamais attenté
à son honneur
est-ce que ce verdict pourrait être et
mon livre a été mutilée bon est-ce que
ce verdict pourrait être rendu
aujourd'hui avec les mêmes lois je ne le
sais pas c'est à dire que notre vision
and où évolue mais c'est nous mêmes en
même temps qui faisons est volée évoluer
cette époque alors ça n'est pas vrai
pour les gens les plus jeunes parce
qu'il débarque donc ils ont l'impression
que cette vision qui disent on est la
leur ils ont raison mais cette vision
elle a été apportée a mené par des gens
qui étaient là avant eux puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas nés donc cette époque qui
avance c'est nous qui la faisons avancer
il ce point de vue sur l'époque évolue
aussi pour nous c'est à dire que par
exemple quand on se penche dans le vert
le passé qu'on parle par exemple d'un
garçon comme gainsbourg qui était plutôt
quelqu'un ou conformiste et pas en tant
que parent l'enfant dont on va parler
ton dit est-ce qu'ils pourraient dire ça
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas la question
la question c'est qui ne le dirait pas
aujourd'hui c'est quand vous avez ces
paroles aujourd'hui scandaleuse ans
melody nelson qui avaient 14 automne et
15 et est aujourd'hui l'eau et d'y aller
18 automne 19 étaient enfin je me compte
dans les chiffres
il aurait ajouté la majorité et y aurait
pas eu ce scandale les lévriers le
scandale du billet qu'il a brûlé d'abord
c'est un scandale tout à fait libérale
de droite puisqu'il se plaignaient de
pas ps de payer trop d'impôts
bon mais il ne ferait pas aujourd'hui
pour d'autres raisons à l'époque ça a
choqué des gens qui sont choqués tout
mais son public n'a pas été choqué mais
aujourd'hui ne le ferai pas pour une
raison simple c'est qu'on dirait avec
toute la misère du monde vous permettez
de brûler un billet est non seulement il
ne le ferais pas mais ça ne viendrait
pas à l'esprit
et s'il avait vécu jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il aurait donc une centaine d'années
d'après ce que mais bon ma mère est
morte à 106 ans il ne retrait bien pu
avoir son temps et parlé et je pense que
il aurait eu une vision
de ce qu'il a fait complètement
différente et là on lui demanderait de
se justifier et c'est si bien qu'elle à
la limite je passerai plus à la dans les
médias parce qu'ils en auraient assez
voilà donc je pense que nous nous
évoluons aussi et les féministes ont
toujours faire avancer la société
toujours depuis le début de l'histoire
de féminisme et depuis les suffragettes
et regarder les suffragettes à quel
point était excessive elle disait il
faut tout leur couper en parlant des
hommes voilà n'empêche que les
suffragettes ont fait qu'à un moment les
femmes ont eu le droit de vote et que
plus personne aujourd'hui dans les pays
libres ne pourrait remettre en question
son droit mais au fond on est toujours
aux prises avec la norme une norme qui
aujourd'hui qu'on prête aux féministes
mais il n'ya pas que les féministes qui
veulent qu'ils veulent qu'ils veulent
faire taire des louis siquet ou ou qui
voudraient voir disparaître tel ou tel
artiste ça ça va bien au delà il faut
font que la société le pouvoir les
autorités vous suivent parce que sinon
ça marche pas des gens qu'on voudrait
voir disparaître il y en a tous les
jours partout
dans tous les domaines ce qui
disparaissent vraiment c'est parce que
tout le monde est d'accord non guillaume
aurignac ceux qui disparaissent vraiment
oui alors oui bien sûr tout le monde est
d'accord enfin où c'est qu'il n'avait
plus le pouvoir de pales de ne pas
disparaître aussi si sk est aussi
possible abandon n'a pas le statut de ne
pas disparaître
voilà donc on disparaît ceci dit c'est
rare c'est d'ailleurs ce que disent les
défenseurs enfin les défenseurs ceux qui
disent que le concept de cancer culture
est un mauvais concept et qu'en fait ça
n'existe pas il répète et d'une certaine
manière ils ont raison qu en fait
personne est annulé personne n'était
face et voilà on demande juste d'être
comptable un peu irresponsable de ces de
ces paroles et donc
donc est-ce que les gens sont effacés
non après ce qui se passe moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la question des
oeuvres en fait c'est à quel moment on
va tous devoir se retourner contre les
oeuvres et dire qu'on veut plus les voir
voilà moi je trouve qu'on doit continuer
à avoir accès aux hommes voilà moi ce
qui m'intéressait dans la sphère
politique et c'est à quel moment
pour quelle raison un moment hdo la
chaîne qui est étonné certains de ses
spectacles les a effacées du jour au
lendemain
après cette affaire là et donc on ne
pouvait plus les voir vous savez bien
que c'est sais c'est que on peut plus
les voir parce qu'on a peur tout à coup
que les gens se scandalise
pourquoi on a fait disparaître tout à
coup un téléfilm de france 2 parce qu'il
jouait richard berry qui au même moment
devait répondre d'un certain nombre
d'accusations ça ne s'affaiblit ce qu'on
s'est dit que les gens pouvaient pas le
regarder normalement ils allaient voir
richard berry richard berry richard
berry accuser tout je ne sais quoi
c'était plus le même regard à partir de
ce moment-là ça justifie qu'aujourd'hui
vous trouverez difficilement des gens
pour donner de l'argent à romane
polanski pour faire un film parce qu'on
se dit rabah des la somme film sortira
ce sera un problème
woody allen elle même problème guillaume
aurignac oui alors il ya deux choses
différentes pardon c'est d'une part
c'est vouloir financer les prochaines
oeuvres voilà on peut très bien dire que
non on ne peut plus financer les oeuvres
de cette personne là voilà mais ne plus
voir les anciennes les oeuvres passées
c'est ça c'est un autre problème je
trouve
il me semble et d'autre part le fait
qu'à un moment on bloque cette diffusion
c'est aussi ça dit quelque chose de
notre rapport aux 9 c'est à dire que
notamment avec le développement des
plateformes de streaming voilà c'est
l'idée que les oeuvres doit couler sans
aspérité comme un robinet à images voilà
et qui a pas du tout de conflit or il me
semble qu'une oeuvre intéressante
ça doit créer du conflit chez les
spectateurs lg geoffrey oui je suis à
peu près d'accord avec ça à ce que je
voudrais simplement souligner c'est que
on est dans un pli du temps c'est à dire
qu'on fait comme si l'avenir sera la
continuation d'aujourd'hui or je ne
crois pas parce que déjà ses oeuvres qui
scandalise bon elles ne vont plus
scandalisé parce que elles ne seront
plus fait il y aura d'autres oeuvres qui
apparaîtront qui seront sûrement aussi
intéressant et toutes ces oeuvres qu'on
ne veut plus voir ou qu'on ne montre
plus avec le temps ça va devenir des
documents presque des documents
historiques et contre lesquels on ne se
battra plus c'est à dire que par exemple
si on attaquait chaplin
on va pas mettre aux oubliettes toute
l'oeuvre de chaplin
parce que c'est une très vieille oeuvre
et que chaplin le personnage chaplin est
devenu un inconnu pour dire il faut être
très âgés pour se souvenir de chaplin
dans paris match qui dit qu'ils posaient
avec tous ses enfants donc je pense que
ce problème est tout à fait réelle ce
côté qu' il ne doit pas y avoir
d'aspérités mais n'oubliez pas qu'avant
non plus fallait paquet d'aspérités
simplement elles n'existaient pas dire
qu'on les voyait pas mais les aspérités
ne sont jamais passés dans l'est dans
les systèmes tels qu'ils existaient à
l'époque
ou soit disant c'était liberté quant aux
avis et trois chaînes de télévision ou
de win
il ya strictement aucune liberté dans
l'audiovisuel vient n'avait guère plus
dans la presse écrite c'est que si vous
des bordes y est si vous êtes inquiet
des personnalités la politique de de
gaulle si vous vouliez faire un film par
exemple sur la pacification sur la
guerre d'algérie
vous n'aviez pas la possibilité ni de le
faire ni de le diffuser donc cette
espèce de d'eldorado cet âge d'or où
tout était permis n'existe pas
simplement on saurait faire des choses
qui à l'époque il y a longtemps été
permise et qui ne sont plus autorisés
aujourd'hui les la norme existé et elle
était terrible parce que aujourd'hui
vous avez quand même les réseaux sociaux
et tout ce que vous voulez qu'ils sont
des juges
bien sûr mais qui sont en fait des
outils de diffusion faire qu'aujourd'hui
on ne peut pas empêcher la diffusion de
quelque chose dans le monde voilà dans
le monde
la chose va partir elle sera critique et
on essaiera de la bloquer mais elle va
partir à l'épaule que moi je me rappelle
d'un très lointain jeunesse sous charles
de gaulle et georges pompidou
vous aviez liberté d'expression qu'ils
étaient réduits à la norme à la norme de
l'époque je vous remercie tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission rire
autant de la honte c'est le titre du
livre de guillaume aurignac et le
dernier bain de gustave flaubert c'est
le nouveau roman de régis jauffret
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]